this sports gods up in the clouds in
another dimension we join them now at
their monthly meeting so the key is to
lean in with your shoulder and hope your
traps take the brunt of it but there's
really no good way to take a chair to
the head all right everyone settle down
I have an announcement
basketball God has retired all right but
we found a replacement and we think he's
going to help us connect to a younger
audience GN Blake launch come up here
our new got a basketball Wendy and Blake
what does he like 14 I'm 12 actually but
thanks
so first let me say it's a privilege to
be up here with y'all my first
initiative as the new god of basketball
is to create the next go I bet you've
got some good friends horse racing are
my friends I'm glad word well I'm
actually referring to the greatest of
all time goat a once-in-a-generation
era-defining superstar right now it's
LeBron before that Kobe and if you want
to go all the way back to the 1900s
Michael Jordan but with the mambas
retirement the time is ripe to introduce
the next NBA goat but but what about
Steph Curry's aney oh well I cam of the
puddle partner Cece could be the neck
it's so wet boys so you ding-dongs it's
the splash sibley it's the moist man oh
it's the waters the water now it's the
liquid Fran oh it's the h2 I do you
didn't continue please word Steph Curry
of the splash bros is a legit choice -
no that's sibling but he's 27 that's all
I want to take a step back and break
down what makes an athlete great so let
me ask you guys what makes a player
elite in your sports how about you
cycling uh what separates an elite
cyclist from the rest of the pack
performance-enhancing jur discipline
great answer discipline is dope but have
you ever considered social media
in basketball we're no Laura talking
about rebounds we're talking about re
vines re grams re tweets what do you
guys like to share on social media I
like to share clips of lou gehrig image
macros image micros I like to share
sponsored content I like to share Ellen
videos she's really funny you know I
like that man I should get a facebook
for word dirty jokes I like to share
Adele videos she's she's the voice of
generation go huh oh damn it on social
media music is fire now music and
basketball five-alarm blaze so I reached
out to some of heavens top designers I'm
talking the angels who created zebras
the ocean Dwayne Johnson you name it and
had them cook me up a prototype for the
next NBA great I give you the drew be
half Kobe half Drake now watch this
trobee give me a fadeaway jumper and a
top 40 single you used to call me the
black mamba Lena when you need my dogs
call me the Black Mamba lane I when you
need my fadeaway jumper oh god oh god no
dude two of eight no he's not ready for
the real world
stop holy noises music at basketball oh
my god oh my god if I die I'm a legend
you used to call me the Black Mamba late
night when you need my dogs you know
what forget about Robi I'll bring in you
guys something better to bran yay I'm a
genius and I'm taking my talents to the
White House
Oh God